well we are less than a week away from
the People vs OJ Simpson American crime
story and it promises to shake up the
way that we view the crime in a century
but members of Nicole Brown Simpson's
family are upset that it focuses on the
murder of her and not her life but we
went back to our vault to give her voice
tonight and a big picture remembering
Nicole in 1985 on her wedding day to OJ
Nicole was just 25 years old before her
murder and all the years et covered her
husband
Nicole never uttered a word seeming to
prefer living in a shadow but now her
sister Tanya feels Nicole's story is the
one being lost as OJ's saga is headed to
the screen two people got brutally
brutally murdered chopped to pieces
basically and let's just say it how it
was and this is not entertainment this
is not the John Travolta's the Cuba
Gooding the David Schwimmer this is not
Hollywood
but Nicole and OJ did live the Hollywood
life 12 years her senior Oh J once told
us marriage had tamed him
I think Nicole my wife has brought some
stability into my life I never thought
I'd remarry but it was a lady that came
and offered me all the things that I
needed today while Simpson sits in a
Nevada prison cell Daily Mail com
reports he is planning on getting out
next year and as furious over the
miniseries their source claims he said
quote these expletive were making this
movie may find out who the boss is when
I sue their expletive this
never-before-seen photo from the 80s
shows the then happy couple poolside
during their wedding video we see how
much love there was between them and
amongst the guests Robert and Chris
Kardashian we're very proud of Jay he's
finally done it
we're very happy and we hope you guys
are happy and healthy and have a nice
long happy life together
it was such a tragic story and Sheena
Cole was so dear to my heart and and I
think about her and have such great
cherished treasured memories forever in
my heart Nicole and OJ divorced in 1992
the following year she made this
terrifying 911 everything that an
abusive partner is charming on the
outside but a monster behind the closed
doors
well according to an executive producer
on the People vs OJ the series does not
portray Nicole Iran out of respect to
them and to spare the family's grief
it'll be interesting to see if any
family members show up to the premiere
tonight